(whimsical music)
♪ It must be love ♪
- Hey babe, have you seen
my key, (keys jingle) ope.
Found 'em!
- Do you think we should get a dog?
- We don't have any time.
You're in the toaster all day.
- Oh yeah, I guess that's true.
They're a lotta work.
- Yeah.
- And I guess it needs to be walked and--
- And it might be too hard if
we have a little baby toast to butter
- Whoa.
- And a dog, and it like eats the babies.
It's just like,
- We didn't get it
- Now we got it, it's
gonna eat our babies.
- No honey, honey, honey, honey, honey.
Don't cry.
We didn't get a dog.
- I'm pregnant.
- Would you still love
me, um, if I had no crust?
- Yes.
- Would you still love me if I was burnt?
- Would you still love me
if I had peanut butter all--
- Yes, okay, yes, okay.
- Oh.
- Damn, I'm looking thick.
- Oh yeah you are, gimme some of that.
- Mmmm. I'm gonna give you some of it.
Yeah, I'm gonna give you a piece of it.
- Oh yeah, come to me, you
gonna be my French toast?
- Oh yeah (speaks in foreign language).
You know, cause I'm the French Toast.
- Yeah, mmm.
- Should we do Chinese tonight?
- I'm not in the mood.
Mexican?
- Oh I had that for lunch.
How about pizza?
- Nah.
- Thai?
- Burgers?
- A burger, I had steak for breakfast.
- Oh yeah, (bleep) I forgot.
I love your your scent.
- You do?
- Yeah, you smell like burning.
- Oh, that's so nice.
- I was at a supermarket and the deli guy,
he was like, "Is that Mold?"
And I was like "That's not
mold, that's just my face."
- My face, yeah
- Have I told you this before?
- Once or twice, or fifty times.
- Should we go out tonight or stay in?
- Stay in.
- You read my mind, we're so in sync.
- We should quit our jobs.
- Yeah, lets quit our jobs
and move to the beach.
- Yeah, yeah, and then we'll
barter for everything we need.
- Yeah, (bleep) corporate America.
- Yeah, (bleep) capitalism.
- Yeah, (bleep) that (bleep).
- Yeah, we'll do that tomorrow.
- Yeah.
- No, not the scarf, I hate the scarf.
- What, you love the scarf.
- Only in a universe where
love means I (bleep) hate.
- Oh come one, it's the scarf!
Psst, hey, hey toast.
You up, you awake?
- Mmm.
- Do you, do you think ants
can tell each other apart?
- Mmmm.
♪ It must be love ♪
♪ It seems that only I can see ♪
♪ The love she has for me ♪
♪ It must be love ♪
♪ It must ♪